[Music]
good evening I'm Alexander Rose the
executive director here at long now
and this morning started interestingly I
got an email from Stuart brands and I
might be late when I got an email saying
well planes still not taking off and
then I got the email
and these are all from London then I got
the email well we took off and we got
turned around we're not gonna make it
but all is not lost
luckily I've been going to Burning Man
since 1996 and so I'll be your host this
evening thank you wasn't what I thought
I was gonna be doing today the first
thing I want to announce is much better
news than I got this morning which is
that we passed our fundraising goal for
the interval by a hundred thousand
dollars thanks to all of you as of as of
today was five hundred and ninety five
thousand three hundred and six dollars
and we spent more than that making it
but it was a it's a huge success already
we are filling this space up we have
we've been having amazing talks in all
different formats there it's been a
really interesting place to try out new
formats discussions work groups readings
and so if you haven't come please do
come
tonight's long short was actually given
to us by the Burning Man organization
and this will get out of the way the
whole thing of like what is Burning Man
I don't think we really need to answer
that question to this crowd but just in
case there's that one person will we'll
cover that with the long short enjoy
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I actually described Burning Man not as
an event that takes place but as a
community which is a gathering of some
of the most creative extraordinary
individuals in the world on the website
it says it's an experiment in social
living and that's just what it is it's
not dictating what the social living is
it's letting us all find out how we can
make this work together to enjoy
ourselves and enjoy one another like to
find my community to find my tribe to
find my people who I could just be at
home with
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so Burning Man so I'm gonna tell one
playa story the very first year I went
to Burning Man was in 96 as I said and
my memory of that was pulling in very
very late at night it was probably 2:00
in the morning after law as you know
long drive and you pulled off and there
was not a very cheerful greeter like we
have now it was a very surly
battle-hardened DPW guy and he's like
you got a compass in that car and yeah
and drive 12 miles east and it was
blowing windstorm and it was dark and
and so I drove for 12 miles through dust
and then the city just starts appearing
out of that dust and I realized I was in
a new kind of place a new kind of both
urban environment a new kind of urban
experiment and it was it was in 96 you
could drive cars from place to place
there was rave camp and we kind of
camped somewhere out in the middle away
from things and the people in the tents
about 100 feet away from us got hit by a
car that night and and I remember that
moment in my head going wow I wonder I
guess this is the last year Burning Man
and there was another person who died
that year and something else and it was
it was such a bummer and a you know
passed around the camp and and then it
wasn't the last year party man and then
the last year of Burning Man was the
next year and so we're now 25 years into
the last year of Burning Man and the
institution is proclaimed by by Larry as
an experiment to try and be a over a
century long institution so we just need
75 more last year as a Burning Man and
we're there and so tonight we're going
to be talking about that Larry
[Applause]
I'm gonna make my room marks pretty
brief I know that really be a relief to
some of you you know me was along now
folks invited me here tonight to answer
a question why is the man still burning
this morning I asked my assistant Kellie
this question and she said she's always
thought a burning man as being like
those birthday candles that you can't
blow out and and I think she's about
right her interpretation of it brings to
mind for me my son's first first
birthday party he was uh he was just it
was his snarling his first birthday
party was his first birthday and his
mother had baked a cake a big white cake
covered with icing and I brought it out
put it on the table put a candle in the
middle and lit it and then reached out
and picked him up I saw that so he was
sort of semi hovering over the cake in
order that he might blow the candle out
and and he did succeed in that but
somehow in the process he managed also
to find his footing and suddenly stood
there facing this giant cake unsupported
and full of wild surmise and I think is
a
in his mind he had somehow figured it
out that it was his cake and and no
others because he began to he began to
sock the cake he approached it and and
in fact began to tread on the cake he
was actually walking on the cake and his
brother said mommy mommy stop him and
Patricia did something that I'll always
remember I think it was the most
handsome thing she ever did she said she
looked around it she looked at him and
looked at us he said you know it's his
birthday let him do what he wants so we
got up and like a jury retiring from the
courtroom and went into the living room
next door and and and waited there
quietly see what would happen and and
when he reappeared actually Patricia was
wise what she did was a very wise thing
and I'll get to that in a second she was
also very shrewd and I think she knew
that that once he found himself alone
with his missed him and his cake and
that he would you know seek for more
companionship and seek those who had
been around him all his life and loved
him and supported him and sure enough he
turned up and he was he looked like some
kind of miniature abominable snowman he
was covered from head to foot in
frosting and I it cost me to reflect Pat
wasn't much of a meta physician but but
I am and and I thought well you know she
really did a deeply proper thing here
because everybody knows that on your
birthday it's it's it's it's not only
your day but you should be
allowed to have anything you want you
know you shouldn't be subject to other
people's interference that their
sanctions their their needs their
dictates that it's your day and and I
think that's because the birthday
doesn't celebrate birth itself if it
were celebrating birthday out to give a
trophy to the mothers out there the
other wants to do that work it's it's
it's it's fact it has your birthday it's
not because of anything you did you just
slid into this world but it's in honor
of your your first Advent in it it's in
honor of your being birthdays are simply
because you are in the world it
birthdays like so much ritual activity
regard something of unconditional value
and and when you think about it well
we've got Burning Man up here he's in
his birthday suit and and nothing is
required of him out there no one expects
him to take out the garbage no one no
one is waiting him to for him to do any
favor for anyone in fact all it's
required of the Burning Man is all it's
ever been required to the very madness
to just be there just stand there that's
it's all he has to do it's enough and
and and I think that some of that if
we're there for his birthday to honor
his being then and in his pure being as
he stands at the center of this huge
city which I'll show in a moment the the
center of all attention manure simply
radiating being throughout the city if I
show you something
that's our city
isn't that nice it's a thermal imaging
thing I believe it is or rate and and
you can see oh they gave me of I wanted
one of these I've always wanted to take
one of these to Burning Man and and and
do that thank you but you'll see that
that you know at first glance I'm a
student of I'm interested in
anthropology I'm interested in
architecture in particular I'm
interested in and and and kneeled I
think architecture fascinates me and I
traveled to several men to several
temples in my time and and in my fame my
favorite was Teotihuacan in Mexico the
Great Temple mejor and Teotihuacan and
and what's fascinating about it is
nobody knows what it represents it was
so old by the time the Spaniards came so
old by the time the Aztecs came they
were far the news and nobody knows what
anything represents I mean you can make
some educated guesses
but I like that it's the separate of all
belief I'd like looking at it because
you you could see the owl you look at
that design you can see how it engineer
it experi experience you know regardless
of belief and our city is rather like
that you know it looks with this
configuration and with this axis you
most of you've been in the event so you
know where these you're aware of this
great processional way that that extends
from our setting city like the pistol of
a flower that marks the dividing line
that creates a kind of a perfect
it turns it's a mirror image in fact
what it does is it's it's it's bilateral
symmetry so what it's called and and and
this extends out from the social center
of our city which is a great structure
which itself is bilaterally symmetric
and and and it's the largest it's larger
than the Roman Colosseum and it's it's
the center where people come to commune
with one another and it's come where
strangers come to meet people it's a
place where the entire city becomes
acquainted to us it's devoted to
communion and and then it extends out to
the man and the and then ultimately it
extends out to the temple and I'm gonna
go back let's go back to the man for a
second each one of those nuclei existing
along that axis are basically something
in some sense devotional places our city
is saturated with ritual if people don't
talk about that they talk about how wild
and crazy it is pushing boundaries how
its innovative constantly innovation
engine of innovation and all this stuff
and and and I guess that's radical
enough pushing boundaries going where no
one's been the new but it's really about
also in equal force the old it's about
the other side of what ritual what
radical means radical means pushing
boundaries but it's a very funny word
its root is radix comes out of it which
means root and radical the word also
means whatever is deeply situated in our
nature what what it what is innate
what is soulful what is interior it
means both those things at once in our
city means both those things the time I
keep wondering if people will finally
ask me well this radical expression and
radical self or
there's always radical stuff in the
principal's what does that mean well it
in some sense it being sad it's that is
that is that the people can live in the
moment there but at the same time they
do so in contemplation of continuities
of time that extend all the way back you
know to the beginning say your birthday
when you came into this world as being
and all the way forward potentially into
the future and that future that that
that if you live long enough then you
very much hope to affect especially if
you have children and and if you look at
the in an environment like that rituals
have have originated everywhere if
people don't know certain things to the
man for instance is is bilaterally
symmetric of course as we all are and
any thing with the vertebra is like that
and with a with a spine rather and when
the city before the man even appears and
before the people appear before the city
even exists before there's a road before
there's anything there a crew goes out
and they and they and they pound a stake
in the ground in that ground and and and
that and that T at stake is is located
right down there so that it's on an axis
with a man spine no that's not because
of any metaphysical idea it's because
the man is meant to stand if you look at
the radiating streets that marked the
arc that forms the city every one of
them the sight line and every one of
them converges on the Burning Man and
that's that's because there's simple
fact that the that when they pound that
stake in the ground they're creating a
kind of axis mundi a kind of world navel
a place from every dimension every
turning every configuration in
coccidia surveyed and it creates the
entire inform shape of the city that one
point in space that means experientially
that when you go back and forth is
people constantly do to get out to where
they don't goddammit
to get out to where the to get out to
where all the art is in the greater
arena around the man that that what they
see before them is the man hovering
before them seemingly suspended between
earth and heaven and and and they're
they're constantly looking at him that
way in fact they need the man terribly
because if if people know that when the
man goes down everybody gets lost but
people have been looking around them to
tell him where they are and they're so
often disoriented that it almost becomes
where you are is almost tantamount to
who you are and and and and and so they
looked for the man to find their way
they're always looking for the man the
light of the man to find their way and
and and so Anna says he really is
radiating identity he really is
conferring identity on everyone
he's an object of constant contemplation
now not because we said you've got to
contemplate him because we just set up a
world where you have to contemplate him
in order to survive and what's happened
over the years what happened early on is
that the crew that was doing it doing
that survey they they would they
invented original ritual now I can tell
you when ritual ritual raw or what
rituals arise and how they've arisen to
the hint about the history of our life
together on this planet and and in that
often I think happens when when groups
are are involved in Missouri themselves
effectively of their toiling they're
doing work and merging their energies
and when you merge your energies in a
group your ego begins to fall away and
and and and and you begin your African
their effort because becomes one of one
in front of one great energetic flow and
and if if the work you're doing is
dedicated to something that's beyond you
that's greater than you like the man is
in relation to the city
if you if you do that long enough what
happens is people start inventing
rituals to to to fathom the the deepest
meaning of what they're doing it happens
spontaneously it's predictable really
and and what they do with the man every
year they go out and they put a stake in
the ground they find it may they find it
by using a satellite and and find that
the very spot and then they pound it in
the ground and what the what the crew
does and they invented this together
they collaborated it just happened
one day it's personal come up with a
hammer and just tap it a little another
one the hammer tap it a little tap it a
little and a little until every one of
them has in Milan's of energy and in in
in in defining that space that defines
the world that defines everything and
believe me they're aware of it they know
that those actions are forming the
experience of everybody who attends
every one of you who has attended has
been affected by that and and that's
become ritualized the lamplighters it's
another ritual we could easily you know
we could easily automate that we could
we could put you sell ourselves and we
could just you know we could do it the
modern way and and they would just turn
themselves on and said it we made it a
matter of great labor people labor
together to do something that's
meaningful that creates identity that
fuses them together the relates them to
everybody else and we'll continue to do
it that way every time every time we
monkey with a city we create more
lamppost areas I've got an idea
my mind is going to and the lamplighters
are always equal to it because they have
they have so invested their energy in
that it is their identity they are
lamplighters their bearers of light to
their fellow citizens and do you
picture of the man on that great axis
that defines experience that great axis
then is like the spine of the man isn't
it it's just like you're spying upon
which you know and upon which you know
it should be religious to talk to a soul
on which your soul those nervous centers
those lesser brains you know arranged
beneath the big nerve center that that's
where our that's for our deep emotional
life that's where our spiritual life
takes place is on that spine and and and
here's the spine that reaches out that
encompasses the entire designer the city
the city then is a ritual object the
city itself not just a man and and that
you'll see is aligned with the temple
and of course you've all been to the
temple and it surely must be you must be
sensible to the fact that that is a
ritual not that anybody's out there to
enforce the reverence of it
it's bilaterally symmetric like any
church like any temple you've seen
except for those hideous ranch-style
churches they build on the suburbs and
they don't work very well and and that
this urge to sacrifice things is so
strong and of course you know that's
dedicated to those who who died beings
it's the end of being not the birthday
but the other end of it that's dedicated
to being and and those those beings you
have lost and and and probably those
beings you have lost if you're
celebrating if you're if you're
observing they're they're passing that
that have informed what you are and that
even Minh in their passing remain in you
because you've merged with them and some
some deep sense you've merged with them
in your heart you place with them and
and and they inform they inform what you
are from day to day and and the
interesting thing happened I was talking
to a gentleman out front I mean it's the
designer of the inuksuk that was in the
temple a year after this last year and
in 2013
I believe did anybody see the temple in
that year with that with that wonderful
polished basalt effigy at it's very
center and I was out with ya give him a
hand and I was I was out there with him
and I was out there at the well he was
there at the rock guard when they were
just putting the last touches that
polished basalt law and and and I I sent
to my friends lightning and sin who were
the great impetus behind that project
that you really ought oh it was a
wonderful yo rock yard and all kinds of
rocks stacked up and I said you want to
take a couple pallets of rocks out there
in addition to the inuksuk because if
you lay them down by the man what people
will start to do any you make some
examples in pile one upon the other it
was it was the statue with stones piled
it was like a Karen and in in in in in
very and very like a human body and
balance so as your honor is if on a
spine and and I said if you lay them
down what you know what people are going
and make a couple examples pile a few up
people are going to imitate that and
then what's going to happen is I don't
care what they believe but what's going
to happen is that is it a sieve an
example and they'll start stacking rocks
to an imitation of that and then what
you'll have or people down on their
knees in front of the Inukshuk down on
their knees making the image of the
great the great the great object the
great ritual objects and making it
themselves they'll do that and they did
they did more than that they not only
did they start doing that but there were
little the whole inside of that it
didn't have altars some of us fretted
about that doesn't have altars so it
doesn't show people that they can make
memorials and and in tributes and they
can't they can in shrine and sacral eyes
things
and and what actually happened is the
people who gathered there we shows you
how contagious culture is and and in how
compelling ritual is they they they
reach down among in the D G that's our
acronym for decomposed granite and
that's spread all over the ground it's
as a burn shield and and they started
taking those and they took them over to
the sides it's and the whole entire
sides of that temple were louvers with
what turned into what they turned into
shells they turn those into shelves and
the entire and finally I went out the
third day and I looked you know and in
all those shells were covered with
little in their Shooks that people had
made and of course what they were
memorializing is that being that meant
so much to them last year we had the man
up at the center of a little tented
pavilion and I had a shop there to
anybody come to it a Larese did anybody
come to a Larese Oh a customer good I
hope you in you're happy with something
you've got we couldn't buy or sell any
things just gifts and but I've got
stories about that but and and there
were these kiosks around it around the
man that shot light up on it and and
then there was an empty space inside and
Jack Haye the designer a year before had
done them for Garbo cult and people had
they look like penises they were they
were rocket-shaped really and and and
you know and people did with him is they
disco dance and I'm pretty profane
performance but but after what happened
what laughter what happened at that at
that temple the year before then I I
looked at
the and that I realized well these they
turned them into altars in the inside
you know they were these straight disks
and and that you could you know that
might serve as some kind of shelf or
altar I supposed and and what they've
done is they picked up all the DJ and
they they found around them and they
started piling started making these
little inukshuks and that's just that's
how contagious this urges especially if
you unfasten it if you can unfasten it
from doctrinal religion and just invert
the order of things
a slightly and say this isn't about a
Supreme Being this is about being being
supreme and that's what they were doing
that's what they do in the temple being
a supreme and and that's what they feel
around the man when they stream out
they're like the protoplasm and surround
it and for the first time in this in
this in this experience in which they've
continually as they sort of celebrated
their being and there's great birthday
party where they you know we don't tell
them what the man means he doesn't
represent anything as I say he just is
himself he did not represent anything
he's just himself just it's him being
there it's birthday and and and and all
around him you have people being
themselves and virtually following
balling and on to birthday cakes
wallowing in their birthday cakes you
can have your cake and eat it too and
you can wallow in it out there it's
going great big wall of being I'm
fishing the hot gospel now and and so
Minolta mately what they do you know is
they they stream out to the man and they
spent all this time not only referencing
it but but but reaching down deep into
themselves and projecting some sense of
their own being out in the world for
radical self-expression
and then they gather around the man and
there are thousands gathered around the
man and and and he's dissing Osier of
all eyes he's at the center he's the
unmoved mover he's the he's the axle you
know they've been the wheel whirling
around him and and and for the first
time the entire community witnesses
itself as it sits in contemplation of an
object that's like them but greater than
them and they experience themselves
together for the first time and and I
was talking to a billionaire the other
day and he said he was going to Mars and
he meant it and I asked him well what's
uh I was candid I've been trying to be I
said you you don't think you can make
money off this to you he said no he said
what I do is uh you know I thought maybe
he's deluded and you think it's ok neom
is on mars and it's a big paying
proposition he said no I I divert money
from my other operations known to make
profit and I put it in this I liked him
already
and I and I said so so you so you're
doing this for the sake of transcendence
an old-fashioned idea and he said yeah
that's why I'm doing it I said well I
mean I won't kid you I was soliciting a
donation from him
I said well you've been to the event
more than once and and and you you've
seen the people come out and you've seen
them gather around in a circle and
you've seen them and you've seen them
surround this this this this giant man
and you and and and you know that it
when they look at it they having
witnessed themselves they they they now
look up and and witness something that's
that's that's greater than they are and
and and you know that's transcendence to
me says yeah I know so we agree we're
both in the same business so that shows
you some of the uses that's his
consciousness and being could be put can
be put to especially in a world with so
much of our identity is from commodified
and and and and and and in in turned
into a million a billion personas and
but what happened to the persons you
know we turned ourselves into products
if we brag about how much were you light
and so makind of activity is of crucial
importance and especially as it can lead
us to to to think and it's with the
birthday all the way back to your
beginning and and and and and and and
all the way forward to a possible the
destiny of beings that will arise even
after you've you're gone IIIi think if
we have that then our prospects look
pretty good and and I'm thinking about
my son because he'll be wrong when I'm
gone you know my home I loved his first
birthday I'm gonna miss his last
but I want to see him LaVon to inherit a
world in which things of real value are
valued most that's all I have to say
this curse I'll leave that one up don't
keep that here now I want to keep this
place with no weight can you put the man
back up just for a second
there I did it no no one let him have
that next no I need my water it's only
the founder of Burning Man would have is
on leader bottle of water with them on
stage I can't get it off
you can keep that on there it's by the
way the other ritual the ring so you've
mentioned this hundred year timeframe
and that long now we obviously we have
another base ten timeframe of ten
thousand years it's not ten thousand and
so one of our biggest challenges
obviously is a similar challenge I think
that you're facing is you know what is
what is the next generation you hand it
to and even more critical I think is
what is the generation after that like
and you know I have a question for you
yes the ten thousand year it's I mean
just think about a hundred years for us
is very challenging and and but ten
thousand don't you have to go to some
kind of sacred mall don't you have to
have monks or something yes yeah okay we
don't know yet Yeah right I hope it's
not robots cuz that's not gonna be any
fun for everybody it depends on the
robot well I suppose so
so my last robot made my time so oh I
know a guy who and he also did had to
deal with a funeral place and he did
these he's a robot that would a cocktail
shaker shake your asses oh really
yeah yeah I don't know it was on
batteries or what anyway I'm sorry I
just wanted to so well first I'm
interested in how you got to the hundred
years and then what you're thinking of
in terms of succession plans so if if
Burning Man is gonna last that long
you're not going to be as you mentioned
you're not going to be the one doing it
for that entire time how does it how
does it survive its founders and and
even more critical to me is how does it
survive the general one generation after
the founders before it's a before the
institution of itself has been
ritualized
well how to be ritualized in the right
way to be ritualized in a zen-like way I
think in the subversive way but we began
thinking about the future when we came
to the point where some of us were
getting approaching what would normally
be retirement age and though I have not
retired and and and then began to think
but they then looked at what we wanted
to see and what we wanted to see was the
culture spread globally and and and then
if you look at that well that would take
a lot of work in time you know that
that's not the kind of thing you can't
do that
can't create a gadget and spread it all
over the world the culture doesn't work
that way and and it's labor intensive in
it and it takes a lot of human contact
to do that and and and we thought well
that that would take some time and I
would well exceed our ages and it's
about the time we decided that we would
turn into a non-profit and and so that
it because we didn't want to see it end
up in the hands of our heirs and assigns
and fighting over the you know the the
core purpose the business sir who gets
the shower curtain there you know some
other decimal thing and so we so we
realized that we had the nonprofit that
the tool we'd have the annales you for
years was it was very serviceable very
nimble as a business an today and let us
do things we couldn't do otherwise and
we realized the new tool for this time
to come in this long span of time would
be a nonprofit so that in some way it's
always been dedicated to the community
but so we moved to that how do we come
with a hundred years our lawyer
suggested it
knowing that this is the most soulful
one year later I would leave money I'll
take bets on this that our lawyer who
created that nonprofit first as is as
more soul than any other attorney in San
Francisco if not the West Coast and and
she was the person to do it she just
helped set up by Cesar Chavez's a series
of interlocking organizations that were
set up as a non-profit with a
hundred-year charter no we just said
that yes to condition our actions to
Humble us to say oh oh gosh this has to
list a hundred years and so things are
dependent on personalities have to have
to be reinvented somehow the some passed
a thing as to self reproduce so it's
it's it's more than having a long-term
business plan business plan is the least
of it it has to do with creating a we
realize we're going to have to create
some kind of institution and we're only
like a quarter of the way into it
frankly that that can that cannot be
separate from its object cannot be
separate from what it wants to produce
it has to be what it wants to produce so
this has to be a really soulful
organization because if it isn't that
then it can't create that I mean you can
be a jerk and turn out you know good
mayonnaise but you can
you know right but but you can't create
this sort of thing that way you have to
be the thing you want and so the the
many you know the many things that were
those huge challenges along the last 25
years that were the insurmountable thing
whether it was police and fire issues or
permitting issues or deaths how do you
build in the raziel the resilience
within the organization to you know
you're gonna have to overcome you know
another 75 of those years of that level
of creativity within the organization I
mean most organizations would have
failed at at least one of you know five
of those things along the way and and
you guys powered through and I know that
a lot of it comes from the energy of
your own community but are there other
things that your the community comes
from our energy it's a very reciprocal
kind of thing the know we've went to a
whole series of existential challenge
and just when you're done with one and
you think you've left that behind or
below then only to discover another you
know we thought when we we thought when
we got there's always someone who it's
got worse in a sense in terms of public
discourse because for years people have
been saying this is the last Burning Man
Burning Man was better last year than
they say so now they say it every year
and now it's depressing that there was a
there was a there was a prestigious
fashion magazine that actually ran a
online editorial saying that Burning Man
was over because it had become too
fashionable figure that out and and and
and and it's now being said that the
rich and their curdling gaze that and in
and into celebrities you know those dead
turkeys ham that buy their bear regard
this 1% and really turns out to be more
like 1% of 1% which is I'm sure
questions about yes we got many of those
but let's let's just answer that
question now I mean how does that how
does that affect the do you feel as
though that's going to be an affecting
thing I mean I all this is we met and
survived all kinds of social challenges
people forget you know we we make black
su sitio I mean we just make it up every
year we keep what works and we're
conservative that way we keep things
that work but that was actually one of
our questions is that you know there's
many everyone laments the changes that
every year the different rule or the
different level of law enforcement
although every bounce society on but the
the but what are those constants that
actually that are the things that keep
it working what are the things that you
hold on to you mentioned you're
conservative in that sense well we are
conservative but I don't know it we're
pretty pragmatic and we work with what
we've got for instance it said now that
we have 40% newcomers every year 40% it
just happened it we didn't really
control that process it emerged ticket
sales but we actually I'm pretty
comfortable with that I actually think
you need infusions I don't think it's
enough to say that you have a right to
come because you come I think that you
actually need no energy medon't have a
lot of news coming and that'll lead to a
kind of intro P to crime no you don't
want everyone to be getting older one
year per year that comes well that would
be rather depressing but I mean so the
other long-term institutions in the
world are universities and schools
there's some that have lasted over a
thousand years and they have yeah with
just 25 percent new you know just in the
undergraduate class they have 25% new
every single year and that's clearly
that energy is what's helping them move
forward through time and so it's
interesting to sit here you say it's 40%
it's even higher in a sense at Burning
Man that that's how much new energy it
takes to turn in I think it keeps things
pretty much alive and it's not as if the
burning of an van is an and B Lana no
it's not what happened when we started
when you know the the problem was to
supply ticket supply or demand exceeded
supply by a factor of god knows it's
hard to plumb how big it would get if
you really could just oh but I don't
know it would be well it'd be disastrous
the city would would would probably
increase six times over overnight have
you ever seen a city that grew that fast
so that's me so you see it's asterisks
and but are you saying it's only
disastrous in its rate or are you saying
it's disastrous
I mean what did we do don't look at
Santa Rosa and see well yeah but the
thing is the disaster the rate or the to
local joke what is the disaster the rate
of change or the total number it would
it be okay if it was six times larger
but gradually grew that way well I don't
know we don't know we we we think that
there are we think that there are means
at hand to increase the capacity of the
big city if there's another thing but I
not only were you talk about that just
now that you could increase capacity at
the center I don't know I'm not talking
about like just the I'm not the legal
framework of permitting or anything but
I mean just on a broader sense and it's
actually one of our questions from Dana
is you know for Burning Man to survive
does it have to be at the black at Black
Rock Desert yeah and Labor Day weekend
doesn't that way now anyway when people
said well how there was radical
inclusion and then my colleague Marian
famously said well guys I mean all the
clowns can get in the clown car
that's an illusion it doesn't really
work that way and and it's not enough
hope we don't you know so the it's
really a problem it's not a quantity
problem it's a qualitative problem can
you grow that and maintain creative
maintain the quality of relationship
between people that's really the
question I don't think there's some kind
of masa fiying point god knows there
been cities vibrant cities that produce
wonderful things in the history of
civilization so that's kind of a
parochial point of view but but the real
growth or some of the significant growth
isn't going to happen in Black Rock City
it's going to take place abroad right so
satellite events is actually one of the
questions that also came up and you know
we have you know we've got the event
then we've got decompressions and and
pre compressions here as well as in
satellite cities where people are
driving to just for this event and then
we've got the satellite events how many
satellite events are there now and how
well I think they'll grow yeah because
I've seen that curve before I don't see
why it wouldn't reproduce similar
circumstances you don't need a desert to
do it really what helps what makes it
reproduce means that reproducing is that
people internalize the values they we've
been saying that they the principles
described in ethos and it's real and
they internalized that ethos they take
it away with them and so you can
reconvene the city in any place you want
and that's starting to happen and there
are events that are growing and I think
that will happen
it didn't be really the project had
seams that go beyond events but but but
they are immersion experiences that's
what we call them and they have a way of
creating almost what you could call
conversion experiences and and and so
that I think that will assure you know
especially if everyone can if we could
all be Confederated and and and and help
one another in a network and that's what
we're trying to create with the project
and if we can do that then I think
you're not talking about you know you're
not talking about you're talking about
millions of people in the end and and it
it does seem to work in various contexts
you know we're very interested to see
what if it could work in the third world
and how it would change right could
solve your permitting problems - well
you've always had to get you have to get
a I'd rather get a permit from the BLM
than a war chieftain frankly though it
might seem easier would be easier with
the words your first year yeah the first
day and so it's so that growth that that
paralleled the demand increased and man
tickets the wave that washed on our
shore then fell down the shingle and
started washing up on the shores of all
these communities all over the places
suddenly the regional saw this big jump
in attendance and people said well okay
I guess enough critical mass we're
convinced that that I contain the seeds
of it and me and other people do and we
can connect so why can't it happen
something where we are and any in any
other business context the parent
company would be appalled by this you
know I mean let's get this straight
these aren't franchises we don't make a
cent from from from any of it and and
any more than then like the anonymous
billionaire is making it making any
money on Mars and and so no that's going
to continue it'll get interesting when
it reaches a point where people fully
realize that that when you saturated the
world to a degree that is you've got
enough people that they can make
significant congregate in significant
numbers you know around that that people
will begin to apply it to their ordinary
lives and we have a lot of examples but
but if we can create a network where
people could communicate with what
they're doing the resources if some of
some kinds can be moved around
well it certainly becomes a litmus test
I mean there's it's one of those two
kinds of people things you've either
been or you haven't and once you've been
you are in some sense converted and it's
very easy to have the conversation with
somebody about it well I think we think
it become replicate to phenomena I mean
it could be very powerful I mean if you
had if you're talking about and it's
it's coming about the Missoula ver that
day and they're autonomous yeah the only
thing that can access to our network is
a pledge to follow the ten principles
you know it's not no one's making money
when they when they get bigger and they
need more help and they want consultancy
we'd sell that to them but that would be
because that would that would help them
don't we make our toilets work helped it
helped them face the existential issues
and right and that's you know that's
fair enough
that's a fair proposition and so the
funny thing is in all this is that there
are only about 70,000 people at Burning
Man
and yet it's know worldwide the Ohio
State Fair is a lot bigger than that
right I mean that's not a lot of people
if you start looking you know around the
world there's various kinds of gathers
it's not that many people I was at
soccer game and Barcelona that 80,000
that yeah 80,000 people except no one's
saying they're gonna change the world
because they won't
and it's when the game's over it's over
experience is over what we're finding is
that people will internalize it and bear
it with them out into the world and and
then recreated it in their relationships
with others since they as they as they
strive to do just about anything you can
think of it doesn't have to be events
that's we're now saying you've got to
quit this event centric thinking about
Burning Man the event and see what else
is going on but eventually we'll say
quit the event centric think about any
immersion type experience that depends
for its potency on sort of withdrawing
from the world you know for purposes of
contemplation as to some holy place and
and and and and and let's let's get
profane and take it back to the world
and see how durable those values are
there and that's where the real game is
going to be won or lost that's it at the
point where we imagine it could change
the world
we don't think just abandoned it there
isn't going to change that but but we
think that it could if it scaled up in
the right way and kept it so I'm since
I'm in the middle of trying to design a
10,000 year clock that's 500 feet tall
and underground and I was talking when
the email exchange around this tuck him
up you mentioned this Neolithic
inspiration of the layout of well it
wasn't an inspiration it just looks that
way right yeah no it reminded me very
much of Chaco Canyon you mentioned tota
lon
but if you seen Chaco Canyon yeah
there's a place down in Mississippi
whose name escapes me that it was part
of the Amarone and civilization the
mound cultures yes and and and and
actually it looks exactly like our city
theory but if we didn't come from that
so well there's there's several
questions that have come in one from
Tyler you know is there a different camp
layout or is there and or what is the
evolution that got to this one what was
what is the ritual that got you there I
mean you
in the spike the radio format where did
that really come from well that's funny
it was just a series of it emerges
historically we we we started out with
the man at the center in the desert in
the 90s and so we had that idea of
somehow encompassing the form of making
it you know this rate and radial Center
and and then we moved off the desert for
one year in 1997 and as sort of doing a
little political dosey doe right the
other maneuver and and and there
inhabited the shore of of Hualapai flag
which is where our production facility
for the event is in that Valley and and
there we followed the shore and and
these were did they just conform with
the topography and it curved a little
bit so we had you know and we divided it
into segments so you could get from the
front to the back and and and and then
when we went back onto the desert and
look at that blank slate I knew then
then we took what we've done Rob Garrett
had a lot to do it my good friend and he
and we he designed an arch we argued
about who came up with the radial lines
I'm absolutely certain and I have
witnesses to prove it that I did
but that's what happened to
collaborative environments he was
certain that he did and and that's
alright he said we were very close
friends and so it was then we thought
and then it became clear and then he
hatched
actually it was utilitarian this is form
and function just fusing beautifully
because if you're going to survey a city
and you're going to create that art
there why not survey it from one point
and then you've got what you got one
survey point
oh it's B it's a beautiful conception
right no it's there's a lot of words
curious all the other cities are squares
and and well if each one wonders
except for Chaco but I think intuitively
everybody also realized at the same time
an aesthetic level and indeed a
spiritual level that that the man had
been at the center of everything but by
performing that the center or the whole
city and every dimension in out of that
unique point in space that had a
powerful it was emotionally evocative
mmm-hmm it was very powerful and the
amount of space between the man and
everything else that seems to be both
growing and and being intentional each
year was that how was that set oh the
space just blowing the balloon up yeah
that's kind of funny what it does how
was that time oh we I don't know we
tried a version um blew it up too much
and everybody complained people we said
and we didn't like it so okay change
said we haven't made significant changes
I've got a couple little changes I want
to make next year to solve particular
problem and which ought to be
interesting but and so someone named it
Sphinx asked a question along our
earlier lines as the the last year of
Burning Man which is the last year
Burning Man basically what was that what
was the year over the last 25 where you
thought it might not actually
what was the scariest here maybe well 96
was chopped it was and that was a very
melodramatic scenario and so operatic
because there was a lot of division
within our ranks but I never thought
that that was the end I didn't believe
that 97 I came closest the year that the
of the playas which well that's the year
that Washoe County police calm and Jared
all the receipts from the kata County
was essentially for friends we're good
friends but then every family goes
through its phases and and and and and
then they took all our money at the gate
they were trying to basically they were
attempting to commissioners are trying
to take us out behind the bar and kick
us and take our wallet and that's what
it was and and it was politics but but
but that didn't come to pass but I
remember they had put roadblocks up all
over you don't get to share this kind of
thing with people you know they think it
just happens and they take care of it
some people think we just call them the
photo toilets so that's what we do I
want to invite one of these critics over
some time and rig all of our offices so
that they'll all be related foil toilets
consents that's all we do this is the
office where we plan and the positioning
of the toilets and here's the sanitation
department where we here's the you know
it's the transportations of toilet
transportation department and the whole
thing will be devoted to toilets and and
because it's what some people barely
think and and I'd love to do that it'd
be a lot of trouble but the the what was
i saying i distractedly
oh they they sent up roadblocks over and
the word went out that it was there were
police and confrontations and they were
gonna stop track
and and and a thousands who would have
come didn't come and so I sat out there
there was a place I could go where I
could see walk to where I could see all
the traffic coming in on the serpentine
Road the gate road and and I got very
sensitive to that phenomenon and you
know you could I imagined it it's like
corpuscles of blood and you you could
see that the flow and and I remember I
looked and looked and looked for about
twenty minutes and and it about broke my
heart because I could see we weren't
gonna make it
you weren't gonna make it people weren't
going to make it in or that we'd end up
bankrupt and we had nothing anyway
personally we didn't have anything for
nothing and and and that we just
wouldn't make it and then we end up
saddled with all these debts that the
county had forced on us because they got
the fire department out thereand the
fire department that we were paying an
enormous sum for them and the only thing
they did during the entire event is Oh
Marion alarm went off in her car and the
guy popped the tonkin and tore the whole
arm out and that was it that's that was
what the fire department accomplished
through the tearing of a million dollars
and and that was well that was and I and
I thought well this is just gonna ruin
us I mean what can we do no one ever
invested in it and who would who would
invest a thing like that
nobody ever invested yeah and and so we
got through it and and learned a lot of
political lessons along the way and and
ended up forming an alliance with the
then sheriff and
and and and we play politics and and by
the time it came around we talked to all
the creditors and we convinced them we
pay them it's not as if we had anything
they could seize at one point I said to
a colleague
I said don't worry we're gonna have you
dawned on me I said we're gonna have a
out of money experience we're gonna
float ten feet above our creditors yeah
what am I gonna do yeah take my truck
Wow and your porta-potties and so about
two weeks before the next year's event
we made enough from the sales and
tickets for that event to pay for the
previous event and and then we just but
we grew and we we dug ourselves out of
it that's what we did it was it was it
was really hard but it was just that
little moment where the only time I can
remember thinking that oh no this might
be it this is the you mentioned a lot
about the ritual and what is what is
created out of the you know the man's
birthday were you is all of that evolved
or is there anything that that's derived
on have yaga pneumos asking you know is
there something is there a past event
that either has you found that event but
either culture or ritual that you found
in retrospect is matching this or one
that this is based on well as I said I I
I see that I'm interested in the
psychology of religion I I'm not
religious myself I'm an atheist but but
I don't see that that that's any bar to
belief in something you could call a
soul or spirit I mean our lives
of course there's soul and spirit the
spirit everywhere the team spirit
you know what spirits like it flies
abroad in the world it's contagious
people catch it right and it elevates
them and it fixed them physically it's
in fact it's the physical part is raw
emotional part is physical first and
then it affects what you think and and
and and and so old everybody knows about
soul I was talking about soul up here
Souls real and haven't you ever heard
the Soul Train and which is soulful I
mean soul music is so full by the way
and and and and I don't even that but I
don't believe in any sort of gaseous
vertebrate you know and I severe I
haven't but but but I believe in
spiritual well I think very much you
know I like to think everyone needs a
spiritual life and everybody has so
everybody does I'm absolutely I don't
care what they think they do and so when
I was talking about an axis mundi that's
an ancient idea you know and it's the
idea that there's a center and and and
and all of time and space grow out of it
you know it's almost like you know the
cosmology the scientists have
interestingly enough and and and and
that creates myths about that hold the
things the essence of things are in
their origin and their creation right
which aren't necessarily rational ways
of looking at thing but the more I look
at life the more I see I I see people
making their own myths constantly and
they get fulfilled - it's really
interesting so I believe in I think all
that means something and you know the
part furthest I get is is in just
positing a very simple idea and that's
the idea that the only spiritual guide
to me is that that that being is
Supreme Being a supreme and if you're
doing something that offends against
being then you've doing something wrong
and what offense against your own being
then you're doing something wrong and
and I don't think it's you shouldn't be
cruel that you should not be cruel to
animals because an an has as as sentient
or as rights I don't think they have
rights I think but I think that any
created thing has something some part of
soul and you know when you get a
jellyfish maybe I'm a man I'm a proud
order if a member of the Order of
ancient or vertebrates
I think they and well so the this notion
that being is the it is an effect the
ritual and the religion is so rich and
delicious ever been about its way to
contemplating being you know right but
that it's that that is the superior
force not something else that's outside
of you that religions are religions are
often giving you an answer whereas we're
sure that is that it's not that's not
what you're mentioning what Burning Man
is and I think well we're no religion
sponsor something outside of the world
you know they impose a supernatural
agency and and and then that and I think
that you just all you have to do is
invert that and and things make sense
and the world would be a lot more
charitable and and people wouldn't be
murdering either over their various
versions of unconditional reality but I
but I'm not a postmodern person I
believe there is such a thing as
unconditional reality and you can know
it when you see it and when you feel it
and you experience it and in its in and
and and it's by first event that we
really do sinners that we are hypocrites
that we are liars that we tend to be we
do change and I think when people
suddenly profoundly change it's usually
because of of that the confrontation
with some
unconditional reality that just you know
that that changes what you are I've had
a miss sighted mystical a couple
mystical visions but I don't believe in
supernatural and and the only reason I
think they were real is because they did
change what I are it was um and that or
what ir that yeah that afterwards I felt
no craving to repeat it not like with
drugs you know no craving to get there
again but that it was completely
surprising because it changed me so I
didn't have to go out and get it I
didn't have to go back to get it I then
to see my man and score it was changed
me not to go back to see the man and I
think everyone's had experiences like
that you know and and that can give you
faith being a supreme then you have to
believe that it's possible for anybody
to change you know the only tragedy is
that we don't only live so well I think
even the worst reprobate give them a
thousand years they might get the tragic
part is we have a limited time and and
so maybe some people don't so we've had
over ten questions come in about gender
gender really the man oh man have to be
the man what does the man mean what is
that he's called the madness he's called
a man you know since we couldn't figure
out at burning worked really well you
know it's
it's a good it's good and it was burning
what burning is great because it's a fir
but it's also describes a state and and
but so then it's burning what burning
person then nothing resonated you know
and and so it was burning lamb but but
but listen I would invite those people
to look at that figure and he was it
looked a little butch this year but but
he really he wasn't you know he he he's
not - why at the shoulder he's not - you
know narrow at the hip right he's he's
he doesn't have a lot of secondary
signifiers for Jennifer you know he
doesn't I guess he shares more like a
pretty buffed up woman but there plenty
of them and offending but you know
they're I know some women but the point
is the please I'm gonna dig myself a
hole but I think I think the point is
that that it's it's in its its there
aren't any sexual organs that's clear
and so he could be either one or one day
you know he's sort of he's so life you
know and he really isn't too much so you
could take it that way under your labor
over that design each year is that
something that you do know I mean it's
evolving each it it's well I'm not sure
what IANA it was designed in various
ways this is collaboration so there are
several people who can say they designed
it the Builder could say design it and
that involved field engineering and
things and so that affected his for him
and then the architect could say that he
designed it because he did the
superstructure inside that the trusting
that the allow us to put that incredibly
heavy thing a lot and it had to go to a
new system and the Andy Johnstone who I
worked with closely it
beginning I'm the one who said I'm 110
feet tall it's time to go big and and no
more small men well it seemed it seemed
just same time for the purpose we wanted
to put it to and and and and but we kept
the you know the outline of the man
absolutely intact it's exactly the same
it looks a little different maybe
because we filled in the spaces and and
you know but so it was exactly the the
same man so that's all we did except
that I in the original design to design
from back 90 which I was my design it
had these little roofs went out the
front do you did you ever see that
version and and then they they and then
the carpenter said well why not and it's
collaboration they said why not you know
do a body contour by bending board and I
said well sure wants do that and then I
went out to the work site and they had
that on and and and the roofs which had
already been made where they put to the
side and I said wait a minute
I'm stuck and I say look you can fasten
that in and it actually creates a nice
texture increases the intricacy it
aesthetically this works and I looked at
them and I knew as soon as I left they
were going to take that out because they
were proud of what they did and they
didn't want these stupid non-functional
roofs to get in the way and and sorry so
you know let go and but this time I went
to Andy and I said I can bring those I
can bring those back so we we did them
they going up the front and made these
alcoves and he did the actual rendering
of that and and so there you got at
least four different people in and many
more when you get down to actual
carpentry that maybe there were little
touches put on that that
[Music]
that did the design so there you go
that's that's that's called
collaborative art and it's a lot of fun
it's just a lot of fun and there's a
reason it took so long to burn this here
yeah because it was because I had and
legs like this and they were laminate
it's a miracle to damn thing it's a
miracle it burnt it almost oh I won't
tell you there was an emergency I got I
had to call I went into the circle I was
in the circle and said we've got to get
the Rangers and the emergency services
people and and and and and and everybody
and the fire people together because it
looks like it's burned down and there
were these these these holes drilled in
the ankles and I was watching them and
it burned down and burned down and and
and suddenly the fire was below that
because they just but you know Wigwam of
lumber up around it and it burned down
and nothing else is spreading on the
structures what we had there was a
multi-ton cinder a multi-ton of cinder
that was standing there just perched and
and and nobody really you know and I
thought well wait a minute why don't the
fire goes on altogether and we got all
these people are on this one what's
gonna happen I shouldn't be admitting
this
it all worked out well I got this I
almost got thrown out of the circle
because they went to this kid who was in
in a circle and all he know was the
little band of area that he has nanny
had protect and and I said you know we
don't have a radio and I need to call
you know I need to call a couple people
and we've got a kid you know that heads
to the department see and he says sir
sit down so I took out my I show you
where's your ID say it just a founder
you might as well have said flounder and
I wasn't in the hierarchy he knew if he
just had one rung above him and that was
his supervisor and I began to think my
dad is becoming a bureaucracy you know
and so I I said finally I managed to I
have wanted to convince him that I was
speaking from a position of
responsibility I was doing my duty
and I was in the chain of command and
then and and here we have a problem
here's the problem and we need to and I
and I and I reached out at night
and I just touched him on the shoulder
and said son as he was a young man you
get to be my age you can call people's
son and said because you know I know the
common touch you know God is looking at
me you see you have to realize that I
care about the welfare of the people and
I have a happier I have a heavy
responsibility and he said you don't
have to patronize me in the supervisor
came over and she said that she's gonna
get the cops then they were gonna frog
marks me on there
yeah no I left frog-marched me but they
were gonna you know and get me out of
there I was just an old cranky god
Jesus so I I I finally saw my colleague
Oh across the way and I calls her over
and that we got everyone together we
talked about it there was a plan B and
so this is because it wasn't burning it
just burned out and people started
getting antsy as they were still tied up
against the line and someone and always
when the fire was over they got to come
in right even though he was still
standing there I come in
guess there wasn't the fire the fire is
very forbidding and you know that the
heat alone is you know and repels and if
your brain isn't working your nerve
endings will tell you and so we
generally yeah and so so what we did is
we so I said it's our plan B I shouldn't
say this but is there a plan B in case
you see the situation you know I
sketched it for them beautiful so how do
you know I said you have information
that I don't have because I know a
little bit about this and is that is
that a faith-based date how do you know
for sure no one's even ever done this
before
how does anybody really know and you
know when you're on a frontier you know
and so I said to him I said to them well
what's that's we finally agreed that we
think of they go off and we think about
it because we went through the but the
Plan B's could be and we didn't quite
come up with anything that was really
good
and they went off and it was really nice
the guy thanked me he said well thank
you for you know being so reasonable so
I no longer cranky old man I was a
responsible you know elder for something
and
and that was a relief and so they walked
off and then nine minutes elapsed and he
fell and boy did he fall thump you never
never heard a song like that in that
circle the ground shook it was so heavy
and so word it's that now we do learn so
next year explosives in the ankles well
he won't be quieted he won't be quite as
big and but still he'll be very like
when he was this last year and and yeah
well we'll figure out something now that
we have the experience I don't know when
that what was the seven-mile whatever
they brought in the world to expert on
nuclear breakdowns and all the cameras
were on him everybody in the world was
on him and he came out and I kind of
appreciated what he said he was candid
he says well you know we've never seen
anything like this before we don't know
yeah that Trenor an honest man and so
you know so that's you know that's what
that's the kind of fun thing all right
so the the last thing you you touched on
this a little bit and I suspect you know
a lot of people are here actually maybe
we could take a survey how many of you
consider Burning Man in your home and I
think that that's a I mean that's a
thing that's a that's a feature of this
event that you know is not like a soccer
stadium that you know no one considers
that their home that you would consider
this place that you're at for one week a
year to be your home and you mentioned a
little bit in your talk and I'm just
wondering is that the thing is that the
piece of the virus that needs to move
forward is there anything that you want
to say about that that finishes this the
whole thing I mean I think people think
of it as oh by the way the rainbow
people were saying that before we did
I'm surprised they haven't sewers
no they were saying welcome home long
before you know burgers are arrogant
it's in another culture I mean rainbow
people are decent people and I guess you
know use it so this idea of creating new
home basically I mean you're the what
the third or fourth-largest city in Reno
for ten days and I mean effectively yeah
Nevada and I knew if you if you've got a
room to register to vote you could
probably change all the politics and in
Nevada with that possibly solve the
political problems around permitting
we've never pitched in those ones we do
get a lot about its after California and
Nevada and so the second biggest group
which is kind of cool and so I mean they
really consider us theirs which is
really sweet you took us long enough you
know to break into this state right and
we succeeded but I I don't know I'll
tell you one thing we're doing maybe
it's out of context but I did want to
mention it the the the the we've created
within the nonprofit if you're thinking
about how do you keep the spirit in the
soul in it we've created a entity within
the nonprofit it's called the
philosophic philosophical Center and
it's it's not only it's more it's a
program but it's also a means of
governance and in its job is is to be
the collective memory and conscience of
Burning Man it's job is to is to absorb
is to look at the entire history of it
and why over that period how the tenant
principles emerged and to a point where
they could be described and and and in
what in an entire history of that a very
practical way and and so that when we
make decisions in the future the
philosophical Center will have the power
to say wait it can't be to anything
I am its chairman it can't be telling
anything
I had a beetle in originally and then it
was a post and I thought they're right
it shouldn't be because what are some
jackasses and so what he could say stop
and let's engage in discourse let's talk
let's other people about this policy or
that feature of operation let's talk
about that
you know something like the
philosophical Center all ended up
talking about the plug-and-play camps by
the way and and and and and decide is
this is it's is consonant with those
values and in fact there is a there is a
sort of Jude doctrine or jurisprudence
that's written into the charter of the
project and it says about the principles
it says nothing less than all of these
ten principles combined will really do
you just can't have one principle you
know and that you think it's really good
contradict they all have to there are
all reflections of the same thing and
and and and it's an organic and they
have two nothing listed so then we'll
look at a problem and and and and people
even when the people who have the
memories are dead their memories will be
preserved institutionally that's the
whole point of it and and and it and and
and we can continue that had these very
soulful and informed and indeed rational
discussions about what what actions have
led to what results how the picture with
that what median experiences that the
principles came out of and and and then
proceeded into the future doing that now
I I don't know there are any other
organizations nonprofit or otherwise
that have a philosophical center but
that's something that's just a beginning
in our minds of a way to preserve the
spirit and so
of it into the future so that because as
soon as it loses this memory and as soon
as it gets used to not exercising a
conscience then it's over
it won't work anymore if the thing has
to the organization has to be what it
wants to manifest so it's got to be this
way and we're just as we always have
this is no different from the hole in
the ankle of the band we're just sort of
guessing but we're going forward but
we're on terrain that no one in anyone
who's had experience like us we want to
hear it where we have enough humility do
we want to go out and find out whether
any organisation like us is doing but
but we will find our way it's always
looks so dubious at first few movement
in the dark and and and you don't have a
lot to guide you except your faith your
faith in what experience has taught you
in the past and so we'll try to remember
there thank you for creating an amazing
home for all of us okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you